las vegas has a familiar look mostly
single family homes and single-story
businesses our valley is spread out but
at city hall there's a new effort to
help the city expand by changing our
skyline john langler looks at how las
vegas could grow up
in las vegas medical district it's
already underway you can hear change
right behind us this used to be home to
small offices and small homes now it's
unlv's new medical school our community
is growing faster than we can really
keep up it's one of the most visible
examples of a metamorphosis las vegas
literally growing up city councilman
brian knudsen for so long las vegas has
been full of dirt lots
but it no longer meets the need of our
community bottom line las vegas needs
more homes knudsen wants to encourage
developers to do more with less
rethinking how empty lots like these can
be maximized connecting dense homes with
transportation and services if we go up
to three four five six seven stories
you start to see a lot of more resources
for our community and a lot more
opportunities some parts of the plan
have already been approved by the
council more are on the way i think the
biggest challenge we have is imagination
you can't stop change jessica saylor can
imagine taller neighbors she lives in
scotch 80s the medical district is a
taller neighbor she can already see i'm
hoping that we can find a balance
between what it is that needs to be done
to support the area and the demands that
the city has years ago she expressed
concerns about older neighborhoods being
overwhelmed by new development
now she has a more pragmatic approach
you can't fight against it but i think
you can work with it key to the plan are
incentives density bonuses making it
more appealing for companies to build
taller buildings likely it would involve
discounts on permits and other tedious
parts of construction that can cost
millions i think it scares people and i
understand it thinking about a big
looming building is not what i thought
about when i thought about las vegas but
it's what knudsen hopes becomes the
city's future i think this is the
beginning of a very different las vegas
john langler live local now